It's time for the moment you've been waiting for.
I can
go pretty low.
Lola.
L.
Yeah.
Excuse me.
Preparing the outfit reveal.
Yee-ha.
I mean, what were you guys expecting?
This is my true form, guys.
And I have a hat now.
Oh, my God.
Is this height?
I also have like, my hat has physics, too.
Whoa!
Anyway, I mean I also have this hat too.
Okay, okay, okay, all right.
Sorry.
Anyway, presenting the real Skinsuit debut.
Here is your champion.
Landing in Dadwood Canyon.
Round 1.
First Blood.
Now, time to fuck some dudes.
Nice time, Bo.
Well, if the price is right, I'll do it alright.
Hey!
so
so easy hey congratulations dragon you paid a 60 to unlock
me.
Yes,
Alright.
Now you know why we went through six loops today.
You finally did it, Dragoons.
You've unlocked me.
The newest deal or update.
The newest character in Battlebirds.
uh what do you mean scammed how could you say that it's me
it's worth it i swear it's worth it we all know when a new
character gets released it's like super op and then they
nerf it later after making people buy the character because
it has to be super op so that people will spend 60 to buy to
unlock the character because they want to win it's it's like
It's just pure capitalism.
But congratulations on spending that $60, guys.
I need you to, I do need you to scroll me up, though.
But, oh, check out my boots.
Like that little shiny tints and little spurs.
Yee-ha.
I'm your Canadian.
cowboy anyway I guess we could move a little bit higher I
guess nothing really I don't know if anything is exciting as
we get higher it's just legs it's it's legs from here but
but then we have the hand whoa you see you see how my hand
fingers move too guys what Oh, yeah, I can, like, bounce up
and down as well.
Look at that.
I can move my hands, too.
Oh, and then my little belt is dangling.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know why.
I feel like I'm like, well, technically, I am sort of, like,
re-debuting again.
How many re-debuts am I going to get, God?
but yes look at that look at my belt oh and the shadow too i
need to make sure i don't accidentally uh press the wrong
button uh because like i'm if i press there's a button here
that i press that would take me straight to my face and like
i don't want to accidentally press that so i'm laughing more
because i'm more nervous
but yes you might see uh my color palette changed a little
bit too uh so oh and you might see an aviators as well at
the top all right let's hope that i don't fuck this up but
yeah i have a gun now but if like uh youtube was like no
guns allowed don't worry i can i can hide it so they won't
If I get struck by the TOS because I have a gun, I'll just
be like, I'll just be like, poop.
Yes, being a bounty hunter is hard work, guys.
I do have scars on my other arm, on my right arm.
Yes, I also have a little belt here, too, to hold all my
ammo because I always need light ammo.
main gun of choice is a deagle though uh because we all know
like not really good with the uh the doki wing i'm not i'm
not the best at the doki wing so um it is a little awkward
that that's my choice of gun but that means that means i'll
get better the more i practice the better i'm going okay
it's not a deagle sorry it's uh it's a revolve i'm sorry
guys it's a revolve Look, I don't know much about gun names.
I just know gun I can I can shoot the gun and people die
That's it.
Look, you paid you didn't buy the collector's edition for
the bounty hunter.
That's on you
The the collector's edition of the collector's edition of
the bounty hunter would include a Bounty hunter that knows
the gun names, but you went the cheap route.
You went for the $60 standard edition of the Bounty Hunter.
That's why you only have one skin, okay?
You only have...
If you bought the collector's edition of the Bounty Hunter,
the debut Bounty Hunter skin, you would have got the rare
skin.
And that rare skin, that rare Doki Bird Bounty Hunter skin,
would have known the gun names.
That Doki Bird would have known the different gun names.
names okay she would have known the gun that she was
carrying um jokes on you guys you can't you can't refund
this you can't in the t jokes on you this isn't steam it's
jokie verse jokie verse does not provide any refunds so you
will not get any refunds you like how i'm stalling so i
won't let you guys see my face because i'm building up the
anticipation you're like what does she look like whoa all
right let me move like one centimeter more and then go on
with my tangent anyway uh yes um you guys knew what you were
gonna get in the doki verse chat doki verse does not provide
any refunds what you buy is what you get yes i have a
bandana now I actually used to have a bandana.
You know what I'm going to say?
It's like a...
It's basically like a buildup of my past, present, into a
future.
When my very first skin suit actually wore a bandana just
like this.
So this is like basically a tribute to my very first...
One of my very first skin suit had a bandana just like this.
Well, not just like this, but it was like...
Similar colors and similar design.
Okay, anyway.
Let me scroll.
Let me move up a little bit.
Ooh, now you see a little bit of the hair.
All right.
For those who are like, she's flat.
You have not seen the reference sheet yet.
That's it.
That's all I'm going to say.
You have not, you have not seen a reference sheet yet.
That's all, that's all I'm going to say.
Okay.
Like, look, I have, it's because like everything is like,
it's like, you know, everything is like, I could have like,
you know, a sports bra.
You don't know that.
You know.
Anyway, guys, uh, whoa.
Um, we do have, we are missing the rest of the face, though.
Ooh, do I move one center meter above?
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I can, I can, like, fuck with you guys more a little
bit.
Let me see, where is it?
Oh my gosh, where is it?
Is this one?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so I have a little feature that I can, I can like mess
with you guys a little bit that comes with the Bounty Hunter
skin, which is Whoa
Wow When will we get When will we see the face?
Oh my god When are we gonna see the face?
I don't know
Anyway, uh, I feel like, guys, when I do show, when, oh,
hey, you guys can see the bottom of my, you can see the
bottom?
I just need you guys, I just need you guys to know, um,
there's a lot of announcements after.
So, because I know a lot of people are like, all right, saw
the face, close tab.
But, but there is, oh, you see the feather here?
There is a lot of announcements right after, guys.
And by a lot, I meant there's a lot of announcements.
All right.
I feel like I have to zoom in a little, though, because, all
right.
get to the face now.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Uh, don't FOMO us.
I'm just telling you guys to stay a little longer.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Alright.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
I'm gonna do a countdown.
Okay?
I'm gonna do a countdown now guys.
Alright.
5.
4.
Okay, actually, I mean, mess with you guys a little more
too.
All right, there you go.
So your immersion will stay a little bit.
All right, are you guys ready?
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
one hello everybody hello hello yes this is what I look at
this is my newest skin suit the bounty hunter um okay so
like I'm not used to being so fluid and uh articulated on
stream um Because I, it's been a while.
Actually, no, I've never had that experience before.
I've never experienced, like, being able to move so much in
general, to be fair.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so one of my favorite features here for this one is
that I can do this.
I love I love this expression the most And And of course I
specifically requested That I wanted this face to
Okay So yes The smug is still there The smug is still there
but I also have a million different emotions uh that I can
do so oh yes how could I forget we've the best um the best
member on this channel um he's back guys
we got dad we also stuffed dad into his skin suit as well so
he's back as well guys now he can also be on stream with me
yeah look at him he's so bouncy dad is back dad is back he's
a super long boy too um but yes uh we stuffed dad into his
very own skin suit as well um and he really prefers being in
the skin suit now He has bigger claws and he can dig.
He's a tracker.
So if you don't know, like, I mean, it's pretty ironic
because, like, Dad was originally a weaner dog.
And now he's like, you know, and they're really good at
tracking people.
And, you know, in bounty hunter lore, we need someone to be
able to track the people for money so I can, like, kill them
and get money.
Obviously, I'm going to choose the dead part because it's
just easier.
It means I get to carry less weight to the police.
So I feel like if it's dead or alive, it's 100% dead.
Because then I don't have to worry about carrying cargo.
And it makes it easier because Dad can...
Doki Amber Doge can...
Sorry, not a Doge anymore.
Doki Amber...
What are you?
What?
He is some form of dog.
We've discovered a new breed of dog.
And, all right, all right, dad.
You drop down right now, dad.
Woo!
All right.
Also, let me show you guys.
Guys, some of the expressions that I can do now.
Was it worth the day?
Are you guys okay that we waited a day for the debut?
Are you guys okay with the weight?
Was the weight worth it, guys?
Was the weight worth it?
all right so all right so you might have seen in my trailer
video my uh gameplay trailer video that uh i can have aimbot
eyes now so so this time i have legal wall hacks and aimbot
so surely my gameplay is gonna improve now right and i can
like zoom in i can ads has a special feature where I can ADS
with my eye so I'll be like ADS time um but yes uh so
anytime I'm anytime I'm losing I'll just turn aimbot on but
it's legal it's it's legal aimbot because it's part of my
body like you can't report me if Like part of my it's a
biological aim bot like it's like how bloodhound has legal
wall hacks when he scans the walls So since this is in my
eye It's legal aim bot I say as I start downloading it
Downloads aim bot but puts red eye on so people will be like
oh she's just she's just role-playing guys Like it's part of
her it's part of her lore and she's just she's just trying
to make it in Immersive guys Alright Okay, another thing I
have it's
Oh What's what's 2 plus 2 Dragoons where am I where do I go?
I'm so lost Dragoons Okay, okay, to be okay.
This is another expression that i really like to make and
it's this
oh my god i love it the the little i feel that it's like
it's like actual dokey bird the bird part
i'm so not used to it it's like i can make faces i've never
been able to make before so it's so weird being like i can
okay so this is frowning but then i can do this you know
like the little the little little teeth like mouth in front
like all right all right okay here we go and then we have so
many i have like three three columns of this by the way i'll
have announcements soon announcement soon but i need to show
you guys this all right anyway and then we have credits we
have announcements we also have credits uh my team of 30
plus people that worked so hard on everything.
But also, look at this, though.
Oh my god.
Is that...
Are you gonna...
You're offering me free stuff?
I love free stuff.
I love free things.
You want to offer me a collector's edition of Elden ring for
free i'm not gonna be playing the dlc but like for i'll take
it because it's free and then we also have all right this
one is also tears uh but uh i actually have tears dropping
down too see whoa tears are actually actually dropping down
on my face i also have Are you going to play scary games?
Did you guys, did you hear that?
Did you guys hear that?
What did you, what's that?
Alright, and alright, you guys saw this already.
Alright, so, you know what was funny?
Um, what was funny is that I didn't ask for this.
I asked for, like, three expressions to be able to be made
uh, during my, uh, during my, for my new skin suit and you
know what was funny my mama was like when i was like talking
to my mama my mama was like if you want me to like i didn't
ask for i didn't i didn't say anything my mama was like if
you want me to make the neck longer i will for you
i thought i was i thought i was so funny and then and then
my papa cilia uh she actually ask you to.
I didn't ask my mama to do it, but I thought it was just
really funny.
And then I swear, my mama and papa were on like the same,
with the same wavelength because they were like, and then
my, my papa, um, she just put it in.
She just put it in herself because I was like, oh, that's so
funny, mama.
And also I have this eyes too, the sparkle eyes, but with
not the extra, So if I just, you know, I'm not as excited as
the other one, you know, this would be like super excited
And then the other one would be like, oh, I'm, I'm, I'm
amused.
I'm amused guys.
Anyway Also, okay, some guys were wondering can I take the
jacket off?
Yes, I can look.
Okay.
No, before you're like, oh my God, she's flat Wait until I'm
like, you see the reference sheet.
Okay.
Look, I have to run a lot as a bounty hunter, okay, guys?
I have to run a lot as a bounty hunter, and because of that,
I have to put it on a sports bra, okay?
People with sports bra, people with boobs would understand.
People with boobs would understand the parallels.
You do not want a good sports bra when you're riding a
horse.
That's so true.
All I'm saying is that you can't have, you have to have a
sports bra on when you're riding a horse.
That's all I'll say.
That's all.
Anyway, jacket back on.
But yes, I can, I can take my jacket off and this is what,
this is what it looks like.
Well, yes.
And, uh, another thing oh yes I can wear my aviators I mean
of course I should be able to wear my aviators it's
literally like it's not like fucking sewn into my jacket um
this I don't know if you guys would notice this but uh the
aviators like this look the aviators part because I really
wanted aviators it was very inspired by uh sniper from team
fortress 2 but like the aviators part I really I really
wanted aviators because you know like gamer gamer glasses
that was a thing back then you know like those gamer glasses
that was a thing like eight years ago where they're like you
have to wear those like gamer glasses because it's going to
improve your performance and then it was also inspired by
sniper from Team Fortress 2 whatever happened to those gamer
Gunners!
Yes!
Whatever happened to the gunners!
Do they still exist?
Are they, are they still relevant?
I don't know.
I don't know if they're still relevant at all.
Um, I don't know if, uh, if they're still, they're still
around.
But anyway, other than that, uh, let me put my glasses away.
I can also, hmm.
But yes, if I'm like, I'm laughing too much, I need to be
relatable and like show other emotions or don't think I'm
AI.
I can force my skin suit to frown for me.
So like, you know, I'm like, oh no, they're going to think,
they're going to realize I'm actually not real.
Because all I do, all I do is just laugh.
And they're like, no real person only laughs and only shows
laughter as an emotion.
She might not be real.
And then I would just be like, don't worry, I can also
frown.
but like I'll be forcing my skin suit to frown so they'll
never expect it
oh god it's so unnatural I just need to make sure I don't
laugh when I say that anyway finally I have this I have the
oh my god can I say no I'm Indy I can say I have mind break
eyes
I was like wait am I not a yeah I can um I have yeah
soulless eyes sorry I meant soul that's what I meant
soulless sorry PG soulless eyes soulless I have I have I
didn't request for these eyes it was given to me um it was
it's the soulless eyes Yes, yes, that's what I mean.
The soulless eyes.
That's exactly what I intentionally meant, guys.
I don't mean anything else.
That's what I meant, chat.
So yes, um, that, oh, I can also take my clip off, but I
don't remember what number that was.
What was that number?
Is it, okay, we're gonna play around with the numbers now.
What could it be?
There's like so many numbers.
Whoa, what did I put off?
Oh, that's the soulless ass.
Oh, yes, there you go.
Yes, I can.
Okay, also, like, I know some of you guys might have been
like, wait, that hair clip.
That hair clip.
That's someone else has a similar hair clip as well.
I just want you guys to know that it was a huge coincidence.
It was a big Because my mama actually put the hair clip on,
like, design the skin suit with that hair clip.
Before I talked to that one person that shared the similar
hair clip.
And I remember I told that VTuber, I was like, oh my god.
not intentional when i do this debut it is not intentional
my mama actually put that hair clip on by herself so yes i
can take off the hair clip anyway those were all my uh the
things i can do anyway uh before i do announcement let's go
to the saloon yes the saloon
oh my god all right this is gonna be where we're gonna hang
out now guys i love this loon it's one of my favorite places
to go to now because okay look in the back though like
okay but look at look at the back over there uh there's two
tomatoes you mean there's more than
oh my god they're multiplying i think my favorite is that uh
that chonky goon over there make making those burlesque
igoons dance for him like okay now that i said that out loud
it is absolutely more creepy than i realized when i said
that out loud um but you know how like every saloon there's
like those like women there that would be like hey there cow
boy you want look they need to make money they need to make
money it's hard times out there um in the wild west chat
it's hard times um and i'm drinking my favorite drink uh uh
doking uh Yes, from which I've made, obviously.
I own Do King Rum.
And so you guys should also buy Do King Rum and invest in my
product to the moon it goes.
Anyway, let's welcome my new chatting, my new chatting area
that I didn't break into this time.
I didn't break into.
I actually, you know, this is one of my favorite
establishments to go to.
The local saloon, you know.
It's just my local saloon, guys.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so nervous.
All right.
Finally, before I talk about credits, it's announcement
time.
Before I give into details about, you know, production
credits and all the concept arts and everything that went
into it, I have.
How many announcements do I have?
I have two really really big announcements and I I am gonna
go with the smaller one first so I asked if I could announce
uh this one oh yeah by the way I have a oh by the way sorry
never mind merch first off merch before I talk about the
announcement I have a new logo now and also merch is up yes
debut merch uh if you go to dokey merch right now you can
pre-order uh the new acrylic stand drawn by my mama who I
will obviously I feel like guys already know who my mama is
but I will reveal my mama in like whoa like who's your mama
don't
Like...
Anyway...
Yes!
Draw him by my mama!
And my mama will also be drawing a huge illustration later.
But like we couldn't get it done in time.
But they finished the acrylic stand!
The key visual!
Alright, I'm gonna pin my mod.
My mod, can you...
Can you write that message again?
Chat's going so fast.
They didn't...
They don't realize I'm a cowboy.
but yes new merch is out there's gonna be even more merch
that's coming out on my birthday because we weren't able to
set all of it up in time so um uh for now we only have debut
merch right now uh but yes i'll put i'll put this away for
now anyway new merch anyway first announcement oh which one
all right let me pin i'm gonna pin silent sweep up because
the link is first okay first announcement um i will be on
the gamer subs v card trading cards um so if you guys do not
know uh gamer subs is uh gamer subs is uh releasing uh
VTuber cards, VTuber trading cards, and I will be part of
the V card collection.
This is also why I chose this week to reveal my skin suit
because people were going to be sent my cards like next
week.
So I was like, oh, fuck, okay.
So, because I had a decision on whether or not, like, people
were going to be given, like, early access.
So, I had a decision on whether or not if I should wanted to
use my old skin suit or my new skin suit.
And I chose, I decided to choose the new skin suit because I
was like, yeah, fuck it.
That should, that, I fuck it.
Let's go.
Anyway, I am also allowed to show you guys the sketches.
The illustrations are finished.
But I do have the sketches here.
So we have the main art illustration.
This is a sketch, by the way.
It's not the finished.
Because I'm keeping the finished versions.
Like, not secret.
But, like, when it's released.
you guys would be able to see the finish but it's just more
or so a teaser so this is the sketch for the full art and
then this is sorry this is the sketch for the other one and
then and then finally we have one for one for the dragoons
too so here are here's the dragoons version as well the
finished copies of all of them and it's sick as fuck the
reason why i'm green is that i am a grass type because i'm a
bird so it made sense i mean they don't have the fucking
wild west type you know so because i don't know it was like
water fire grass electric uh and then we were like well
dragon because we had to make it based off of like uh like
where you're there's no flying type um i would have chosen
flying type if there was so and not like you know i'm my
true form is a tomato in the end so like obviously um
obviously you know since my true form is a tomato it would
make sense for me to be a grass type because that's my true
form all right the biggest announcement um which i feel like
some of you guys have I might as well just show you guys the
video.
Alright, so my biggest announcement is...
What's it going to be?
It is...
Yeah!
That's right!
we're gonna have a pc case yes that's based off of my new
skin suit i think the black and gold looks fucking amazing
in the back not gonna lie the black and gold really works um
super well um but yes um you will be able to see this at
anime expo um uh on july 4th to whenever anime Expo ends and
there's not just a PC case this is basically a teaser for
the other products we worked with Hyatt and I buy power to
design I put a lot of I put a lot of like I guess what's the
word a lot of my input on it on various things various
products with Hyatt and I buy power and for you guys to see
it.
I cannot wait for you guys to see the other merch line with
them.
But, yes, at Anime Expo, you guys will be able to see the
products there.
And I think, I don't know if you're allowed to touch it,
but, but, but, that is why, that is like, one of the hype,
hype things in July.
I don't know if you guys know this, but, if you guys don't
follow me on Twitter, how the beginning of just not just
beginning the month of July there's gonna be a lot of
announcements and a lot of things that's gonna be happening
in July and like the highest thing is only one of them and
because I was like oh my gosh a lot of my dreams are coming
true it's not just a PC case there's so much more and that's
why I also have not done a goals list at all because
Because, um, if I do the goals list, I'm going to spoil some
of the future announcements.
So, because I've been, I've been keeping it in and be like,
oh, I can't talk about, I can't talk about, like, I can't
put it as a goal because I'm going to get it.
And, and that includes a PC case.
And I'm so happy because, um, a pc case is has been a dream
of mine for like like a p not just like a pc case but like
pc gear like gaming gear and everything um has been a dream
of mine for so long and um i'm so happy that it is finally
becoming a reality i'm really really happy and i know like
so many Dragoons have been waiting for like a really really
really long time uh for this and I know that despite you
know you guys have evolved into birds now I hope you're
still excited for this PC case and I was like I specifically
requested that I wanted Dragoons to be a part of my merch
line so like all the merch merch stuff that they're
releasing includes the dragoons um because like they're like
do you just want you or do you want to have other stuff i
was like i want that in there and the dragoons and they're
like okay which form i was like i want all the dragoons all
types of dragoons have to be in there so um i specifically
um because you know i can't couldn't have you know made it
this far or you know got here without you guys and um
without like your support and like uh without your support
and everything so that's why I've always wanted to include
you guys into like as many like merch line or like sponsors
and stuff because like I want you guys with me I want you
guys with me on these things and uh I also like designed
some of the not I guess like I gave
for the merch line as well.
So you're going to see some products.
And I can talk.
When the products are finally out.
I can finally talk more about like what I added.
And what I've like.
Gave my input on.
Because we worked really hard.
It was like a lot of back and forth.
For it.
So.
What else did I want to say.
About the PC case.
Yes.
You guys can finally own.
PC case oh my god finally you can match with me I have a
triangular PC case too oh yes by the way joki merch now
ships to Indonesia we did it guys we fucking did it because
I know like before we didn't have like Indonesia as one of
the shipping profiles but by the way we've added into um
dokey merch so now you can um now you can buy dokey merch
products um and have it shipped to indonesia yes now we you
guys can own a triangular pc case where you can match with
me you guys can finally match with me chat
okay anyway there's also what's there another not i have i
have another announcement all right oh um um there is like
uh a lot of my future announcements coming in as well so um
you guys might be like oh is that it is that is i mean
that's a lot of stuff but i'm gonna fatten you up dragoons
feeding you every month um but yes uh there is more
announcements more announcements coming in i think like
either next week or um um i think like either next week or
july beginning of july or july 4th i think on my birthday i
think it was on my birthday i don't remember uh but you guys
have to wait you guys have to wait two more weeks guys two
more weeks and then you can finally figure out what it is
all right i have a list of things i have to do off we gotta
thank the project team for their incredible hard work on all
of this um i was looking at my chat while the entire thing
was playing and you guys were like oh my god no wonder you
had to delay it and i was like oh thank god now they realize
why i was like you guys have to see it to see why it was
delayed when you see it you will know all right to the
credits we go all right yes first off we are gonna go okay i
can actually like be able to move myself okay we're gonna go
with obviously uh my new mama and um i feel like it was like
the worst kept secret like the moment you're like the hands
um but oh my god i am very happy to have uh kamame to be my
uh new mama for my new skin suit um i was really happy about
it i remember uh talking to them and being like are you
interested and they were like of course yes yes i really
want to do it and then you know it was like instant and then
so um i'm really happy to be able to work with uh kamime
sigogo um as my mama um because you know they uh all right
this is gonna get emotional this is gonna get mushy i hope
my mama isn't figuring out how to translate this on this
part but basically the reason why I wanted to go with this
artist as my new mama is because I really wanted to make
them proud of me as one of their newer VTuber children
Because I felt like I wasn't really able to in the past.
And I didn't really have a lot to give to them in the past.
To show my efforts or accomplish much.
Or really be a good VTuber child.
So this is sort of like round two.
This is like round two.
And I really wanted to accomplish so much more.
and have them see all these sponsors and merch that will be
given in the future with their design to make up for not
having much in the past or like being sort of a little bit
of a disappointment
so i just want that and that's why um i really wanted to go
with them as my mama because i wanted to like make up for
everything and i've always really really loved um all the
stuff they've done um and they've always been super super
duper supportive and uh just really want to make them proud
of me um and that's why i uh uh went with them as my new
mama um and uh yes this will be my new skin suit but that
doesn't mean my old one won't be used anymore or stop being
part of me uh we are gonna call it retro dokey uh because
retro dokey has a lot of stuff coming out in the future
because um some sponsors and um some rich line that's coming
up um they specifically requested that they really would
like to have retro doki be a part of it um and i agreed
because you know i'm more known as retro doki than i am
current yihadoki and so uh retro doki is staying around i
might not be using the skin suit like often maybe like one
to two percent or like i don't know five percent i don't
know um but um we made a lot of memory with retro dokey uh
with the retro dokey skin suit and like clea was an absolute
great mama and um clea actually had a hand with like
designing uh working together with uh with new mama
regarding i'll show you guys the sketches i'll show you guys
all like we went through so much i didn't know what the fuck
i wanted um i didn't know what i really wanted so um um we
went through so many um design concepts before we finally
settled to bounty hunter and i will show you guys uh what it
looks with all the concepts and everything because um new
and old mama were both said yes to me showing uh concept art
for everything so i'll show you guys after the credits and
everything anyway um anyway uh yes see ya i we've now this
uh during the charity uh cilia was the papa um she did an
amazing job because look how fluid i'm so not used to this
i'm like like i'm so not used to being like oh look at that
i could do whoa whoa whoa whoa like wow i'm so i'm so used
to moving like 15 frames per second like uh like 15 frames
per second on so i'm not used to being uh super duper fluid
like oh my god anyway um and uh i'm gonna butcher your name
but i'm just gonna say chow uh did like the assistant and
everything with uh with the with helping sylvia by my true
form my true form my true form they also updated uh they
updated my true form they added more uh they they show me
new accessories if you don't know who rice diet is they are
really uh they're famous uh vocaloid artists uh um and
created shrimp miku um and they gave me a new hat they gave
me new hats and they like they like push some new bones into
me so they updated my my bone structure and stuff within the
tomato form so i'll show you guys when we're at the green
screen oh sorry when we're at the magenta screen i don't
want i don't want to take risk but when we're at the magenta
slash purple screen um i will show you the new updates to my
true form that royce diety gave me it's not just a hat
there's like many other things oh my god okay the funniest
thing about my true form is that they originally gave me
jiggle physics but like as a tomato it was so cursed
i had i had i had boop physics on on the on the tomato and i
was like oh my god okay i don't know
I have to limit that I'll show you guys later.
I'll show you guys.
I was a very sloshy tomato Anyway, all right, let's on to
like um the stream assets.
All right, the stream assets.
Uh, we have a new logo new logo the creator of this new
logo.
Whoa, guys, please don't steal my logo.
It was not supposed to be that HD.
Anyway, so we have a new logo now.
Yes, a new logo.
And it is made by the creator of my very first logo.
The logo you see, I don't know if it's on the store, if it
got taken off the store yet.
Oh yeah, I can wink, by the way.
But we have a new logo, and this would be my future logo to
represent Bounty Hunter Me.
And, uh, this was actually made by the creator of my very
first logo, uh, the one that I've been using everywhere.
Uh, by the way, I have no new headers, no new schedule
overlay, uh, or no new, like, I don't, I, I did not invest
in that.
I'll do that later.
There was other priorities.
Anyway, the reason why I didn't invest on all those other
graphics is because, like, I only let a very, very limited
amount of people.
know what I was going to look like.
And because of that, I had to pick and choose who was going
to know what I'm like.
Because the project team, only a very limited amount of
people in the project team actually knew what I was going to
look like.
All the others were just given like a silhouette.
But those who had to work closely with what I look like now,
like, i gave them i like dm them directly and being like
this is this is what's gonna look like because like i didn't
you know i'm an indie now and i was like oh my gosh i don't
want to make so many contracts because i have to i have to
pay my lawyer uh every time for a contract so i didn't want
to i don't i didn't want to do like NDAs.
So I was just like, I trust you to not leak.
I trust you guys.
So the more, the more people I give it to, the more, the,
the more likely it's going to get leaked.
Cause like, I was like, bro, I don't, I already spent so
much money.
I don't want this to get leaked.
I said so much.
I don't want this, this skin city to get leaked.
Um, so yes, we have we will get the assets later um anyway
uh i'll show you the backup logo though the backup logo we
had uh that was made by uh uh sugar type uh i've always
worked with sugar type a lot for logos and let me oh my gosh
where is she um i forgot i don't know where i saved it give
me a sec guys i'm a professional i'm all right i'll show you
guys the backup logo um because By the way, my first logo,
the reason why they're anonymous is because they're planning
on making a new account and they want it to be, they don't
want us to link to their old account because the reason why
I have a backup logo was because this person that I've
commissioned for the first logo, that person was MIA for
three years.
So I did not expect them to like be back.
so so I had a backup logo main just in case and because
because like I was like oh if this because I really wanted
my my first logo main by my original logo artist because I
really love their logo um so I asked sugar type if they
could like edit a backup logo in advance all right please
don't steal this logo too um but this is what the backup
logo looks like um so like as like the
logo um this is the uh this was the backup logo and i still
i wanted to show you guys i let when i commissioned uh sugar
type for this logo i let her know that it was gonna be a
backup logo um because i did one like i didn't want like
just like an edited version of my old logo um but it was
just i wanted to have as like a interim like a placeholder
and so like i knew i find someone to logo that fit me more
um but yes this is a backup logo but this is the main logo
so i will be using this but i had it just in case but this
will be my new logo it reminds me of dragon ball z somehow
um it reminds me a little bit of dragon ball z um anyway uh
my chat overlay it is sig uh and uh they've made a lot of
chat overlays a lot of my chat overlays over the years um so
you know it's not really a surprise and then i worked with a
new artist it was a recommendation from one of my older
artists uh you might recognize um um this is actually like
um i had a great time working with this artist uh name uh
because the background looks amazing i actually it blew me
away um my I gave to them was that I just wanted I wanted a
saloon uh background and I wanted to be sort of based off
like some of the uh sketches related to the splash art from
the game the fake fake game um and uh um I it was a
recommendation from another background artist that I used to
work with a lot uh from uh Shigo uh who recommended Nameh to
work with me because their calendar was fully uh booked so
then I was like you know what I'm gonna take a shot I love
working with you, and I trust your recommendation.
So, yeah!
Me flew.
It was at the ending screen.
This is why yesterday I did not show the ending screen, my
usual ending screen, because yesterday I was...
I already swapped it to, like, you know, to my new skin suit
ending screen.
And so I was like, alright, we're not gonna...
We're not gonna...
Don't accidentally show it.
Woo!
And that's why we had a little...
A bit of a different thing.
Also, emotes!
Yes!
I commissioned Claire and one of my really good friends.
We've been friends for 15 plus years.
That lazy rat.
We've been friends since we were little.
So, that lazy rat.
rat they've gone through a lot of you might recognize them
as either uh ken or kuru uh we've been friends for like uh
15 plus years uh they had many accounts i worked with them
with emotes and um like in our past as artists and stuff um
i've known i've known uh i've known ken longer uh than
And so, we're going to also, like, rats, emotes were needed
to edit because they were like, oh, I thought you had one
glove on.
I was like, no, it's two gloves.
So, they sent me the fixed version, but I didn't have time
to make a graphic for it.
But, you might recognize these emotes because they were my
favorite emotes.
is back um we have monkey is back and so yes the gloves it's
supposed to be two gloves two but then like um he read the
reference sheet wrong so um so like we're we're we have i
have the edited version of it and so i'm gonna swap it back
like i'll i just was too lazy to making you uh they sent me
the fixed version while i was streaming so like i couldn't
fix it you know there's also a reason why we don't have
we're not gonna be like super fast with changing emails
because like i said i was worried of leaking i was worried
of the the art like um worry of my skin suit getting leaked
so i just like commissioned like you know my old mama and
one of my best friends um and being like all right uh we'll
get haven't updated my emotes because I want to slowly swap
my emotes to uh to my uh new uh new skin suit and stuff so
yes ship is back finally now you guys can spam the ship
every time I was like thank you for the five gift the ships
but I'll be adding these uh I don't know tomorrow or today
depending on how dead I am today how dead I am today um all
right next credit where's my slideshow where is it all right
all right stream assets we're not at the team yet we're not
the project team yet but yes we had four different composers
composing songs because I wanted variations of the music
tracks and everything um and so huge shout out to all those
composers I was like are you guys able to do it they're like
yeah and then so huge shout out now nor may actually made my
original BGMs for retro doki and I asked if they were free
and then I decided because I liked um I wanted to like
experiment with working with different composers and then
like you know um just experiment with different composers
and different styles and stuff because like it helps usually
when I work with somebody I always go back to them so I like
working like finding people that I'm like all right I really
liked working I really like this style I don't have a
project in that will fit this style.
So it helps a lot because I tend, I don't know if you guys
know this, but I tend to work with seeing people a lot when
it comes to projects because, like, you know, we've already
had experience together and I trust them.
I worked with a lot of new people for this one.
As you guys can see, like, 30 plus people.
I worked with a lot of new people.
So, Naonor, Zephizona, Aya and Athoram composed all the most
of the music for it.
We actually have somebody in the main project team that
composed some of the game music too.
So the video, the SpongeBob reference was done by one of my
shorts editors, Naseh 1, 2, 4.
He did the Tomeo reveal and the great...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, sorry, I'm blocking your name right now.
The great Kaisu did the voice acting.
I was like, I gave the video.
I was like, SpongeBob.
They've done voice acting for various other things I've
done.
So like the scoop.
They literally might go to voice actor whenever I have an
idea.
Because I was like, well, you're a voice actor.
And you have a really big range.
And I'm going to go with you for any.
future projects I have related to voice acting and I need
male voice number one.
I mean, anytime I was like, I need male voice number one.
I hit him up because he's like the best, like he did the, he
did the Scooby Doo animation and the Batman one for us in
the past.
And so, um, by the way, he sent me like three versions.
It got longer and longer and longer because at one point he
was like, the more you don't respond the longer i am gonna
make this so then i took all of them and then i just sent it
to my editor and was like all right i don't know just pick
one um um yes he did the batman short he was the voice actor
for the batman short and then retrovis i love working with
retrovis for my teasers it's so good it's so creative i love
their style when it comes to teaser videos and um i will
always if i ever have a chance i will always work with
retrovis when it comes to like um videos like this uh um but
yes um that is the assets i think after that is the project
team project team all right management all right so these
were the people who were in charge of like uh because there
were 30 plus people i couldn't be on the for seven obviously
so uh we had a day a channel for me that was like by the way
behind the scene stuff i will be talking about behind the
scene stuff on tuesday the day after because like tomorrow
i'm taking a break usually i don't stream on sunday um but
on tuesday i will be talking about behind the scenes of
everything giving you guys the work in progress shots of all
the work in progress stuff and everything that goes into it
um before i want to talk about the project team before i i
talk about this i want to say uh the project team has worked
incredibly incredibly hard on this we had the reason why we
had six plus loops is because i had additional notes to give
regarding the audio um so like they were like last minute
rendering and stuff um the the the I was sent there was like
a lot of sound effects were missing and I noticed that and
so we had to add sound effects and stuff um and uh because I
really wanted to have the immersive feeling of a video game
like you're actually like it's not just a regular video like
you're actually in a made-up video game that I fucking
created like that was in my head so um this is actually like
the most I've ever a project and as well as the most
expensive today i won't say what how much it'll cost i'll
i'll leave that in the member stream one day and i'll have a
trigger warning like trigger warning financial
irresponsibilities so um and because of that uh um i really
wanted to like give like a huge shout out to them um also
for putting up with me um because i was like um i was like i
have so I'm sorry if I was super blunt sometimes but when I
get overworked not overworked I want to get overwhelmed
they're like I've been really stressed out lately I don't
fluff my words at all I just go like fix this but yes um um
Nova with Syria Mr. Lex in the management team as well as
like director was nova um and we have only pilot who you
might might recognize uh because i've worked with only pilot
a lot a lot a lot a lot for a lot of my projects and
honestly their graphics is like one of my favorite uh styles
in terms of their graphics and they did the production lead
and UI.
I messaged a guild for this because I message rigor mortis.
If you guys know the guild.
And they compiled majority of the people that's part of the
team.
I brought in the 3D people because I had lots of experience
working with the 3D team.
And I personally, I DMed the guild, Mortis Guild, and a lot
of these people come from the Mortis Guild that were
recruited into this, and it was a huge team because I was
like, money, don't worry about how much it costs.
I was like, I was like, ah, don't worry about the budget.
They're like, what's the budget?
There is no budget.
so bring in as many people as you want
because this was very ambitious you guys can tell it was so
ambitious i've had this i've had this idea for the longest
time this idea has been something i had for a year now it's
been an idea so i'm really happy i can finally implement it
Anyway, Pioneer did the GUI logos.
So, like, the logos you see, like, Dokiverse and the game
icons and everything.
But, yes, they did the logos.
All right, next slide.
Woo!
The art team.
I brought in some of the artists as well.
You might recognize a lot of these artists that worked on
this.
By the way, I was gonna tell this later, but um, the splash
art you guys saw, the splash art will be free to download
later in the community post that we'll be making on YouTube.
So, or wait, did I usually make it on the community post or
just give you guys a link?
I don't know, I'm gonna be, or tweet out the link.
Um, all the splash arts you guys saw, um, from the fake game
will be made into free wallpapers for all of you guys.
The animation, on the other hand, just like um usually uh
like um in the past the animation frames like if you want to
use any of the animation frames as a wallpaper that would be
member locked i would put that exclusive for members
regarding animation frames um if you were like to have a
particular frame that you want to be made into a wallpaper i
will be uploading those frames um animation frames um hd
quality of that in members but the splash art the ones you
saw in the loading screens The ones you saw in the loading
screens, like the Alt-Girl Doki, like the tomato, the
holding the tomato, all of that, that is free.
Those will be free.
Similar with the 3D models that you saw, like, except for
the skins, the Dragoon skins that are based off of my
friends, those are not going to be for download.
Because, like, you know, some of them are like corporate, so
like, I don't own them.
But the regular Dragoons, the regular Dragoons, Retro Doki.
Retro, Retro Doki.
The tomato.
There was actually a tomato model made as well.
Those 3D models will all be free to download.
Those will be free to download.
Then I will tweet about it later.
So yes, look at all these artists we recruited.
I really wanted to have an actual game feel.
I spared no expense.
I wanted to be a game feel.
So like you see, like, Pursu, Tai, Kalea, Kuno.
They did the splash art, the loading screen art.
Then we had Shigo that did the Aishio that did the character
artist, the one, the character select that you saw for like,
you know, Doki, Lunar New Year Doki, uh, Altagirl Doki.
And then we had, uh, uh, Black VT who did the icons, the
character select icons, I believe.
And then Honey, who did the sprays and the sticker art.
Also, huge shout out for Honey because they did a lot of
like, huge shout out for like everybody.
But like Honey and Shio, there's a lot of like last, like
they did like additional stuff because Shio also did the
billboard art as well.
And then Honey, I had like requests like maybe like three
days, two days before the stream.
I'd be like, can we have a sticker of Do King?
It would be so good.
Like I would love to have it.
And then they were like, I got you.
And they literally drew it in like less than a day.
And they added the Do King stick.
Because I would be like, oh, I really...
Because like, okay, at one point, like, Lady Seek Map Man
sent me a really supportive DM.
Before my...
My new model, new skin suit debut.
And because of that, I asked if they could also make a new
sticker for Jack Jesus.
like oh it was i was like oh that's so sweet i'm like hey
can i ask to have a sticker of jack jesus too so um huge
shout out to honey for like accommodating that like they
could have said no i've been like okay but they're like
don't worry um don't worry i can do it all right 3d team
You're going to recognize a lot of these names.
I recruited, I brought in a 3D team.
Well, I brought in Jules because I love working with Jules.
I brought in Legends.
Oh, wait.
I brought in, no, Jules and Squid.
I hit up Jules, Squid, and Haske.
And I was like, all right, bring in any of our old 3D team
into, oh, my gosh.
All right, this is going to be awkward.
I'll be here.
Bring in any of our old 3D team in.
And, like, whichever you guys think that will work.
And then they brought in the rest of the people here.
So, we've worked with Has.
We've worked with all of these guys.
The newest edition is Isaac and Violet.
Violet did the Retro Doki.
The, you know, like, I really wanted it as an inside joke.
I was like, I want Retro Doki in there.
I want Retro Doki, but, like, Retro, Retro.
polygons and I brought in uh low poly I brought in violet
and was like I need this and then yeah violet made it oh
Isaac was our 3d animator and also I think the one with the
most apex knowledge so Isaac was like don't worry guys like
like they were like giving like ideas and input regarding
trying to make it more like apex slash overwatch so they
helped a lot with like giving like um and being like okay
the GUI should look like this the graphics should look like
this similar to how apex does it like all that stuff um but
Isaac fully animated um everything that you saw um regarding
uh regarding the gameplay footage uh so like huge shout out
to Isaac new uh they were a new person I've never worked
with before but I saw their animation and I was like okay
that looks sick
you can make it by the way isaac animated this so fast
because like the 3d team finished all the models for the
fake gameplay footage i think on the 10th i believe i think
i don't remember i think it was the 10th or not uh the 3d
team can fact check for me but they finish the uh the set
the games like setting the environment and everything on
either the 10th or 13th i don't remember Isaac just animated
all of that within like 10 days which was fucking crazy that
they were they were able to do that um anyway so yes jewels
legends Isaac violet hasc uh cart squid and salted fish huge
shout out to the 3d team well those are wondering is that it
is what you're gonna do with 3d world this world will be
turned into a VR chat world in the future I was actually in
talks i was in talks with a vr chat um one of the vr chat um
staff um and uh it's not gonna be instant literally i was
like all right after all of this is done our next um when
you guys relax a little bit there's no deadline for this one
but like we will turn dadwood canyon by the way i figured
they gave me name suggestions i think one was like dad
canyon or something and then the remember it was like gorge
something and then i was like i was research researching
wild west i was like all right what what do we have in the
wild wild west and then it's like 10 of the most famous uh
famous places in america related to the wild wild west and
then i was like it was like what deadwood it was like
deadwood city or something and i was like deadwood canyon
I was like Dadwood Canyon, I'm gonna put wood I was like
I'll reference to a famous Western city
It works, it works Also, member Goons would be like So
that's why she was asking us for Game names Alright, so A
while ago, I think like two months ago Or a month and a half
ago, I was like Hey guys, give me a game name because um
because i need help i need i this might this is gonna be a
wallpaper theme for um this is gonna be a wallpaper theme
for like a future month and i want i was thinking up i
wanted to like figure out a fake game name and then i fooled
you all it was actually for this
that's where i stole battle birds from a member I was like,
yoink, great name.
And now I'll be like, hey, guys, I figured, hey, guys, look
at this cool name.
I, I, like, came up with my self-project.
Yeah.
I was actually waiting for the wall.
We have five wall.
I don't even know.
Six?
We have, like, five to six free wallpapers.
You guys don't even get one wallpaper.
You get five to six free.
wallpapers now anyway um like i said this world that we that
this team i'm a producer so i just chucked money at it but i
did give feedback um um this um uh game this world this 3d
world that we made for a fake game will be made into a vr
chat world in the future um like i said like it's not
something that's done really fast because converting it to a
VRChat world is a lot different then um then then you know
it was not intentionally made to be a world but I figured
because I was talking to a staff member at VRChat because
they reached out to me and was like hey everyone do anything
with VRChat in the future like let us know and I was like I
really want to open a world is it for free and they're like
yeah it's for free and I was like wow I love it when it's
for free I can open the world for free i was like can i have
it up forever like yeah you can for free yeah i was like
whoa so whenever this world um whenever this world is done
it will be there forever
um all right what else what else what else i have 16 slides
oh my god this is slide seven
first off we have to applaud uh bullet bullet bullet bullet
blide i'm so sorry i'm like i need we need applaud you but
like i'm butchering your name they were the main editor for
the video to put everything together and the one where i had
notes for them regarding sound design and it was like fix
sound design
they put all the videos to get they had they pulled off two
to three all-nighters to put all of to to try and finish
this and we really need a like huge show also you guys can
see this poster i know like i'm sorry i got i don't have
adhd i i just need you guys to look at this poster um so
anything i feel like uh bullet really does deserve a lot of
love and attention and i was like really blunt to to to to
them um during the project like yesterday i don't really
apologize and um we were all stressed out um and uh we need
to really give a huge applause and uh love to the video
editor to the main edit main editor that put all of this
together um because like um i wasn't in the server yeah i'm
not on the server i'll join back the server uh later when
i'm like uh when i was like okay i'm gonna join my server
later so my staff was helping me coordinate and stuff um and
um uh my staff was like giving me updates on everything uh
while i was like preparing um just like preparing for stream
in general and they were giving me updates regarding
soundicide so i was giving my staff member the notes and
then like my staff member relayed the notes back to them for
today and uh because i was like really stressed out i was
really stressed out i was like oh no i don't want to like
say i don't want to be like mean um um and so like huge
shout out to them for putting all of this uh putting all of
this together uh and also i want to say huge shout out to
raggy um i saw their amazing animation and um on Twitter and
was like I need you to make the animation like I think
because I was like like she is a one man team it was crazy
because I I saw her animations on Twitter and I was really
impressed because the animation she posted she did all of it
herself like by herself and I was like I think she was the
first person I ever recruited onto the team.
I was like, if I'm getting anybody, I really want Raggy to
be on my team for this project to do all of this.
I know they're also preparing for their own VTB debut, so
please check her out.
At first, she wanted to do the tomato one too.
She was like, she drew the storyboard for everything.
She drew the storyboard for the entire animation.
And then at first, she was like, I can think I can do the
background.
And then the whole team was like no no don't you're gonna
fucking kill yourself with the the like by exhaustion you're
gonna fucking um exhaust yourself no and then at first she
was gonna be like oh i'm gonna do the tomato and i was like
no i'm gonna recruit sade for the tomato i was just like i
was just like no i was like raggy no i i brought in another
animator i i think no
my god and i when we saw the storyboard i was like raggy i
saw the storyboard i'm bringing sade sade has worked on la
my animated shorts uh most recognizable the resident evil
short uh dokey bites that uh she did and i brought her in to
help raggy with um with doing the tomato tomato fake out
trailer um and uh mortis brought in will to help out with
background to draw the backgrounds of the animation um yes
reggie did i don't know you can read her twitter and realize
a lot of her i'm so tired was about this project
if you if you read back her twitter it's like i'm so tired
it was about it was about this project
I'm glad we like we brought in more people to help out
because it was so much it was a lot of it was a lot of work
oh my god um because I was super open to bring more people
in I was like guys are you sure we did I was like okay bring
in as many people as you guys one guys i can i'll hire more
i'll i'll throw more money hire more people if you need to
um um um but yes uh huge shout out to the animation and
motion team um and uh for jaws and uh momo for doing the uh
the character splash animation so you guys saw the i'm gonna
release the wallpapers as because I know you can have them
as uh animated wallpapers as well because I know some of you
guys use like the animated wallpaper function on steam and
stuff and I'll be releasing both the animated wallpapers and
the like the the still images of them for those who don't
use the steam like application to make animated uh
wallpapers and stuff um um but yes Momo is actually brought
in last minute too because one of our animators were like we
need to help out yes huge shout out to this team all right
sorry there's a lot of i have there's a lot of creators okay
all right clear and whoa clear did not draw both of them by
the way i've been blocking trident did uh these wallpapers
uh they this will be released like i said for free uh these
are these wallpapers uh the splash art um uh chow did the
this one and ty did the um the background artist for this ty
also did a lot of stuff regarding like sketches and helping
with storyboards and everything um i want you guys to know
the 3d team came up with the map design first environment
design of the 3d world and then like you know it was built
off of that and just added more and more stuff to it and uh
yeah and then we just we had ty draw the visual art of it as
well just to be like uh just to uh make it more i guess
immersive when it comes to fake game because there's always
like the map art in the fake game portion in the gaming
portion doing like what the map looks like and stuff
uh yeah and by the way okay i'm gonna talk about Alright, so
and then this one was, by the way, there was like, in the
behind the scenes portion, I will be, in the behind the
scenes portion, I will talk more about the sketches, because
there was a lot of concepts and stuff.
There were a shitload of concepts and everything coming into
designing the splash art.
So in the behind the scenes stream on Tuesday, I will go
into more detail about all the concept art and everything.
behind the scenes um regarding building up this fake game
that was made from this project team
um okay so yeah porosu niko did these maps chill did all
these billboards uh did the billboard art to fill the uh 3d
world um so i love i think dad subs was my favorite
Dad, was this your favorite, too?
Was this also your favorite?
Yeah?
I don't know.
I think Dad's stuff was pretty funny.
And then...
That sprays!
Alright.
Dad, we're going to have to move over here.
So, here are the item shop.
is honey uh who did all the item shop whoa sorry the other
all the item shop and stuff so oh my god i love it all i
love all of those i think my favorite um has to be i think
my favorite has to be the okay i think that one that one has
to be my favorite um by the way um a lot of the art we're in
discussion with the uh the artists but a lot of some of the
artwork is going to be made merch that will be released for
pre-order on my birthday so so like this the sprays and i'm
deciding stickers might be used as you know be sold as
actual stickers and the sprays might be sold as charms in
the future or stickers we're not we're still discussing
right now i'd love to have your ideas because i'm doing this
the next the merch release the next merch drop to be like
battle birds themed as if like you're as if you know we go
to apex legend store merch store and you store or like a
blizzard shop and you see like these merch that they only
make and stuff so we're gonna have one of them is like a
we're gonna have like t-shirt with the battle birds logo um
that's like one of the things i really want to do because i
want you guys to pretend that battle birds is a real game so
i love your feedback and your input um like in the next
couple of days regarding what kind of merch you want to see
battle birds have uh it's real to me dokey it's real to me
um um but yes like we're planning on making um the
wallpapers as like postcards maybe or maybe uh a wall screw
tapestry we're still deciding um me and my staff team are
still deciding what to be made of merch but i would love to
have your input as well uh what you guys want to buy make
the character art.
I don't think I saw like the character art selection from
Shiel.
It's going to be a giant diorama.
The giant diorama acrylic stand with all the four, with all
the three, I think three, all the three character select art
and everything.
That's the one that I'm definitely sure that's going to be,
that's going to be made into merch.
And then here are the item shop of some of my friends, the
people I've collabed with.
some of them also um yes some i asked a few of them to do
voice lines um okay i need to tell you the story of the
voice line i had with sachi so we were playing overwatch 2
together i was like yo are you still down because like i
asked her i was like i was like asking sachi i was like so
shachi i was like hey so like i'm doing this reveal on fuck
i don't know where to put myself in because It covers
everybody.
I'll just be off the screen so you guys can see everything.
I won't be selling merch of...
I won't be selling merch of my friends, by the way, because
obviously, like, they own their design.
I'm not going to, like, make money off of them.
The stickers and stuff will be...
will only be of, like, me and things I own.
Like, anyway.
So this is a funny story.
But when I was like, we were playing Overwatch 2 together.
And so I was like asking like, oh, do you still want to be
part of, like I'm doing reveal on Saturday slash Sunday?
Like, do you still want to do it?
And you're like, she's like, yeah, sure.
I was like, oh, I just need a voice line.
She's like, wait, what kind of voice line?
And then we were like playing Overwatch 2.
So she was like, what if I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna
like.
That was so funny.
It's just like, can I just like steal an Overwatch voice
line?
It's like, what if I just steal an Overwatch voice line?
And it was like, Merry Christmas from Kenji.
I was just like, I was like, for you to do whatever you
want.
I was like, no, that would be so fun.
And then we were thinking about, like, okay, maybe we
shouldn't steal a voice line from Overwatch.
Because we're like looking at Lucio and Kenji.
She was like, oh, I need healing.
And then we're like, let's see.
Oh, oh, and then we almost had a voice line of her doing
Doomfist's, Doomfist's, which one was it?
Chivalry is dead.
And then later on, she was like, okay, maybe we shouldn't.
And if you listen back to it, she just was like, hello.
And she's like, hello.
I told her, I was like, I'm going to keep that in.
I'm going to keep the coffin.
Um, yeah.
Anyway, yes.
Look at all these stickers.
I don't know where to put.
Here we go.
I was like, I don't know where to put it.
Put it myself.
There's so many.
Um.
And so, yeah.
So the ones, Doking, I will definitely sell that they they
don't own a tiger they can't own jaguars this is legally
distinct jaguar anyway doking is gonna i won't sell jack
jesus though jack jesus i think might be like might be a bit
of an iffy territory but i will i would sell the doking
sticker um but yes the stickers you see that are not related
to my friends and people i collab with they will not be sold
as merch as merch by the way um what else what else whoa
these are the icons from the character select so some of
them did like friends yes my oh she's there thomas edison my
oh she so black did the uh the icons for the character
select and my friends list so i'm i specifically requested
that i wanted thomas edison uh my o-sheet as it was i was
very specific thomas edison had to be on my friend's list um
i don't know what i'm not sure what to use the icons for as
merch yet um so that's something i'm still thinking of at
the moment um so i don't know yet what i want to do the
icons as um but yeah like the icons that are not based off
of my friends maybe i'll sell thomas edison though um i will
sell thomas edison oh she like like he's public domain at
this point so i'm legally allowed to make merch out off of
him because he's been dead for more than a hundred years so
he's public domain baby i can legally make merch off of him
um and finally here are some screenshots of the map that
this set dressing that they everybody did um it's free real
estate exactly the best thing about being a vtuber is that
we never die so like we'll never be public domain um and
here are the maps of everything oh my gosh sorry a lot of
the stream was talking about behind the scenes and projects
even though this isn't the behind the scenes and everything
oh my god look so amazing um yeah Thomas S and Webb wanted
to make me to make money off exactly I'm only doing what my
oh she wants but it's so pretty um all right back to cowboy
um cow by my scenes are named pretty funny back to cowboy
chatting all right it's time for you to get off all right
here you go um I'm trying to remember if I'm missing
anything before we go to green screen time.
Am I missing anything?
Oh yeah, I wrote a list of stuff I need to talk about.
Sorry, I knew I, remember I wrote a script, not a script,
but like general setup of everything I need to say.
Yes, music will be public to everybody too.
I will make sure I want to upload the music itself, but I'm
trying to figure out how to upload it and like not how to
upload.
Like I don't know how to use YouTube upload, but more so
like what kind a music if i want to make a music video or
something or like i don't know i'm not sure yet but um i
will have the music available to to the public as well
things that will be available to the public um the 3d models
of the dragons plus tomato plus retro dokey um the wallpaper
the splash art as wallpapers um and what else they're right
and the music yes the the music the high quality screenshots
frame by like the frames will be shown given in members only
that will be the only members exclusive that i have i'm
gonna have um uh let's see oh yeah speaking of my birthday
birthday july 5th there's gonna be a lot of other
announcements too on birthday so this is not just the only
announcement that uh we're gonna have uh oh concept art bam
you're right all right
Thank you for the reminder.
I should have just looked at my folder.
Because my folder has...
Okay, so I need to show you guys the very first concept art.
Because, like, it's...
So, the very first one was actually with Clea.
Because at first, I was like, maybe I'll just get a new
outfit.
A new, like, redesign slash new outfit.
With Clea.
So, we were debating...
like a okay let me i need to move myself a little bit i
don't want to move myself though okay let me move myself
here so the very first oh my gosh wait give me a sec uh oh
no oh no okay no okay here you go all right here you go all
right that's better all right so um it was um polar bear and
rat
For the very first concept, we were like, ooh, maybe like
polar bear, rat themed or something.
So that was the...
Oh my gosh, let me move myself.
No, if I move myself, then like, no, I'm gonna be...
Okay, so originally, I was debating between maybe I should
do polar bear or...
It looks like I'm trying to drink this.
but then I was like no that doesn't make sense because I'm
dokey bird oh my god this is not gonna make sense because
like I can't change dokey bird I can't I can't change dokey
bird so it wouldn't make sense so we were like okay we
pivoted and uh my my new mama joined the team uh trying to
figure something out and at first we're gonna be like thief
all right thief so um this or you're just not gonna see me i
can't be bothered right now so um i was like i want dad to
be part of me but then i think we had like a
miscommunication and um we were like uh my mama thought that
i just my wiener dog to be there and then I was like maybe
not I don't know I felt like too tacky for me to have uh my
because you see like B was a dog walker I was like I don't
know if I want to be a dog walking I
don't know if I want to be a dog walking that was like my
new job dog walking the hair in B.
I love the... I love the hairstyle in B.
Oh, B was our favorite hairstyle.
So we kept the B hairstyle, as you guys can see.
B was my favorite hairstyle out of all of them.
So we were like, okay, we're not going to do dog.
But then I was like, oh, I still want Dad to be
representative.
And then so, so my my mama was like, oh, okay, which one do
you want to be to be dad and i was like i don't know i don't
know so i was like i don't really know it doesn't really fit
it doesn't really fit doki amber doge i don't i felt like i
guess like the crow too but i was like what the fuck is f
and then so um um So, we were talking about, like, concepts
of, uh, okay, the hats really.
It was, like, tuxedo mask type shit.
And then, and then, and then, so then we were discussing
more.
I was like, I think I want more, like, K-9-esque type deal.
Like, more K-9-esque.
So then we, I, okay, D, okay, and then we're, like, thief,
too.
We were, like, thief, and then, K-9, and then, all right, D
is a fucking riot, though.
Okay, not gonna lie, but D's.
I love...
So, I saw F, and I was like, I love...
Okay, F was like, F it is.
And then we went with...
We were like, I was like, I think I would like some...
A lighter shade.
And, um...
Okay, D is pretty funny.
I wish you could have seen...
Oh, my God.
I talked about this before.
But I wish you guys would have known what, like, Doki Amber
Doge with a fucking...
um like a gangster costume that was the funniest shit ever
that was so good i wish we you guys saw that you guys
remember me talking about it mint seen it mint i remember
like i remember when i showed mint gangster doki amber doge
like it lives rent free in her mind i can't i can't show it
I told you guys.
Here's your reason why I can't show it.
Because it was before Dokey Amber Doge.
Is Dokey Amber Doge.
Anyway, so we were talking about like, what if we keep the
twin tails and still go with the thief?
The thing is, okay, the hardest part about rebranding and
rebranding and everything is that I was had to make a
decision on whether or not.
i am keeping the thief theme or going with a whole new
different idea i decided it was a very hard decision but i
decided to go with a rebrand with a new skin suit design and
a new skin suit idea because i was like um i felt like the
thief thing was like four years ago doki you know it was
Like, four years ago, Doki, the thief was originally not
even based off of me.
It was actually some random...
I, like, took over her.
I was like, I did full metal alchemy.
It was alchemy.
I created this character.
And I...
I skin walked her so she wasn't even supposed to represent
me in the first place and then later on she was like I used
her as me I took over her for him as a tomato and um and so
she was never really representative of how I felt like I was
um but she was retro dohi is very close to my heart The skin
suit is very close to my heart.
The design concept, everything is very close to my heart
because I've had that, I've skinwalked her for like 10 plus
years.
So I wanted, I was like, I really wanted something that's
more like me.
And I figured Bounty Hunter because, okay, not, I didn't
think of Bounty Hunter.
My mama thought of Bounty Hunter.
Because I was like, I wanted something more FPS themed.
And I didn't really like the super long hair.
So I was like, okay, what if we go with more tomboy-esque
short hair?
So we got to here.
This is where we got to.
Oh my gosh, you can actually see me now.
This was, after that, I was like, I was like, okay.
I want an FPS themed.
and I wanted I don't like tech wear I straight up was like
no tech wear
so I was like I don't want tech wear so my mama was like
well that's really difficult because what we can do is
either bounty hunter or like military and I didn't go with
one because it looked too much like Shibuya had so I was
like I didn't want to look I did want to do like what
Shibuya Hal does but in like NA Western scene but I was like
I don't want to be actually Shibuya Hal I don't want to be
actually Shibuya Hal so um on the eye patch anyway so I was
just like okay we're gonna go I love And I really liked
the...
I really, really, really liked the Bounty Hunter theme.
But you can see that we changed more so, like, cowboy-esque.
Because another thing I...
I felt like the jacket...
Okay, it's gonna be so annoying.
I felt like the jacket having the collars up.
I felt it was too boyish.
Like, I would be a tomboy.
But I still didn't want to be, like, super duper boyish.
And everything.
So I was like...
I and I felt like the the jacket thing is like it would
cover the screen too much It like it might cover the screen
too much because it was long and I was like thinking I was
thinking like Okay, let's have the collar down and um I want
to keep it keep it more simple I need I wanted to have it
more simple as well because I don't like having super I just
want to have like a brand that was like that's me like I
don't want to be like super duper over design and stuff like
that so I like uh kept it more simple and everything I also
had uh uh oh yeah mint I don't know you were here earlier
but we were talking about remember gangster gangster dad
wait no it was like rapper dad I don't know if you saw the
other I don't know you were there like earlier concepts of
of of dad but like i was talking about yeah i wish you guys
saw rapper dad i really i always think about him sometimes
anyway i also had claya help out as well and give like her
take on like bounty hunter and stuff um this was when we
decided to do like a smaller jacket as well because i felt
like long jackets was a little bit overdone we don't really
see like short jackets and stuff so claire was also um uh
giving like insight and stuff on like different concepts and
everything and hey guys be saucier so claire was also giving
like input and stuff for us as well like giving us what like
uh she thinks uh would look good as a bounty hunter and we
also have this as well um we played around a lot with stuff
it was so difficult it was so difficult um because like it
was i feel like designing having another like just having a
new skin suit is such a different difficult process in
general so um we had these from claya and then and then we
were given this as well um i was like no
I saw this.
I was like, I don't know.
Now it looks like I'm showing off.
I felt like I felt like I was showing off at that point.
So I was like, I was straight up was like, no, I know.
Too bright.
I was like too bright I can't It's too bright I can't I feel
like It's not I don't know I don't know If I like this Ye-ha
I don't know And then in the end In the end We got it This
is Oh wait no This is not the end Because we had a different
clip too We had Dad was a little darker Darker fur And then
we had Different clip Because We thought, like, oh, maybe,
like, a bullet arrow, but it didn't look as good as I
thought, so we scrapped that.
But all of this stayed the same.
All of that stayed the same.
Just not this.
It was a different... She gave us the X hair clip earlier,
and then I was just like, actually doesn't look as good.
I thought I suggested, I was like, what about the arrow,
like, bullet arrow?
i was like ah they look as good as i expected so we scrapped
that and went straight back to the default so yeah anyway um
a lot of the inspiration i gave regarding like notes i gave
for like inspiration and stuff i was like i really want like
i i sent like designs of like the mandalorian uh mandalorian
uh sniper from team fortress 2 cassidy from overwatch uh and
um look this was later okay i know some of you guys were
like oh were you trying to copy the the ghoul from fallout i
gave that later after we had the initial concept okay
I did give the ghoul at a later point.
But that was later in the process.
It was later in the process, okay?
Because I know the ghoul.
Yee-ha.
But yes, those were like the design concepts I gave my mama
regarding like how I would like to see in Vision Bounty.
and stuff like that um and this is how i was born not wait
no not born my skin suit was made this is how i've always
been born but this is how my skin suit was created it was a
super long process um a lot back and forth a lot of like i'm
scared i'm like oh my god i'm so fucking scared i don't know
how they're gonna react um um let me see but yes it it's
gonna be a okay okay just you reminded me i will show you
guys the reference sheet okay i will show you guys the
reference guys i'll show you all right okay so this is i'll
be posting this on um twitter later but this is the first
the backside the design on the back um the design on the
side and everything no no stop and then this there you go
you see that right here that's a bump right here okay funny
story it was there was originally no bump and then i was
like can we have a can we can we add
Okay, I specifically, I specifically requested because there
was zero bump at first and then I was like, can we have,
like, can we add two more letters in there?
Can we, can we at least go up two more letters like that's
all i ask i just want to go up two more letters like here
okay if you guys need like extra eyes do not worry but like
right here right here whoa sorry yeah sorry i got a little
overzealous here okay let me like fucking make sure um
everything is the same all right here, just so you guys
know, right here, here you go.
See that?
You see that?
That used to be like actually nothing.
That actually, that used to be like nothing.
And then I was like, can it not be
specifically requested I want to go up like two letters at
least at least two letters
I swear I will show you guys out no actually don't I don't
have the file You're so lucky I don't have the file
You're so lucky I don't have the file I didn't like download
it again, but there was a bump is a bump now anyway anyway
here's the whoa let me grab the reference sheet it's pretty
uh it's pretty big here okay let's see whoa okay i need to
like fix this all right so boop it's a big reference sheet
too um but yes all right so here is what it looks like um
with the i'll have this on twitter as well so you guys can
see everything um so there's there's dad over there and then
there's my accessories and everything it's very bird themed
um yes medium is good too it could have been nothing but at
least we got medium it's all natural
it's it's all natural um um you you guys are watching too
much anime you think that's not medium look we're not here
with like in like helium balloons okay it's not high school
that did that was it the zombie fucking the one where like
she dodges the bullet and the boobs flap and dodges the
bullet that's not that anyway um let's see anyway so here's
the reference sheet for everything post this on twitter
later if i'm not dead uh after the stream uh um i think is
that everything i want to talk about before we do green
screen uh i'm trying to remember i'm trying to remember uh
if there's anything else i want to talk about before we go
to uh green screen uh i'll give you guys Only jiggle fixes
we're going to get today.
I'll give you guys...
I'm going to give you guys Bubba Tomatoes soon.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
I need to remember how to fix it.
Because I, like, edited the physics so that, like, I took
away the bone.
I took away the...
What did they put?
When they, like, do, like, plastic surgery and they added
more Bubba.
What's that called?
What's...
Implants, I took away the implants that my doctor gave me,
that gave me, made me super jiggly.
I took away the implants, so I'm not as jiggly anymore.
The silicone, yeah, yeah.
My plastic surgeon tried to give me silicone on my tomato,
on my true form, and then I was like, oh, maybe not, and
then I had the silicone removed from my tomato form.
Anyway, Ha.
My green screen.
There's so many.
There's like so many things too.
So it's like.
Ah, okay.
We'll do tomato first.
Actually, I'll show you guys the new tomato stuff.
Give me a sec.
I need to like grab it.
I actually, I don't know.
Like I don't know.
Like I need to like look at my settings real fast.
I need to look at my hawkies.
What are my hawkies?
like okay one two three five six okay where the hell why did
i skip two do i not have a two one two three four why did i
skip four i don't even have a four okay all right sorry my
purple screen all right here all right so this is my new
form and i can do this
Okay, anyway, anyway, I can't, I have retro, uh, I have
like, cha-cha-cha.
I have, I have retro doki hat, and then y'all, yeah,
cha-cha-cha.
Okay, but I also, I also have, um,
no no bitches no bitches
by the way rice added that added that themselves i didn't
request for it um rice added it themselves so they like
stuffed some eye implants into me as well my plastic surgeon
gave me some eye implants um and then i think that's one of
my favorite this one's my favorite now i'm gaming oh i
requested this i was like i want rgb i specifically asked
for rgb i don't know how to make it stop how do i make it
stop oh okay i stopped it okay i didn't know i didn't know
how to make it stop.
I was so scared.
Okay, let me see if I can remember how to max it out.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need you guys to see the booba.
Um, what is it?
Which one was it?
It was like the physics.
Arm.
No, it's not arm.
It's, oh, it's a body move?
I'm trying to, I'm trying to remember.
No!
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to look at uh oh my god which one was it oh there we
go physics settings okay oh there we go was it okay i think
i was at was it this one no okay that's not it guys give me
a sec i'm trying to remember let me look at guys it's time
to look at my emails
let me um let me give me a like, oh, let me, let me look at
my, it's time to look at my email.
Actually, I don't, I didn't know you guys wanted to see it.
I should have known you guys wanted to see it.
All right, give me a sec, guys.
I need to figure out which one, oh, there it is.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, guys, watch this.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay, I feel like physics settings.
Okay, oh, they're all at, okay, one.
uh one one because i put it at zero one one uh one oh my god
i'm maxing it out not maxing it out putting on default
because i had to like i had to put it all at zero okay guys
are you guys ready
oh my god okay okay
I put the silicone back in
It's not that bad It's because I'm not moving as much Now
you know why
The tomato ain't right Okay wait harder you guys will see it
okay no it's because okay it's because like i turn it like a
bit down you guys want to see it okay you guys want to see
the original physics oh don't worry i'll show you guys the
original physics now you'll know why this was guys this was
the original
i tone it down this was the original settings This tomato's
not doing so well.
Guys, plastic surgery was a mistake.
At least somebody is getting some jiggles.
Okay.
Now make it RGB.
You're right.
Okay.
Whoa.
Take your meds!
Okay.
Anyway, I gotta fucking fix myself.
I gotta...
Let me fix myself real fast.
But that was the original.
I'll fix the... I'll fix myself later.
I'm too tired right now.
I want to... I'm too tired to fix myself.
Um...
Okay.
Now we're back here.
Alright, I put back my...
suit back on.
Veggie tails.
All right.
So screenshot time.
Screenshot time.
So like I said, I can do.
I think this is my, this one's my favorite.
And also the, the, the lip bite.
That one's also my favorite.
It's so hard to give you a screenshot because there's so
many expressions i can make now like take your camera and
there's this one i like that one too that one's my favorite
expression too
um and then
um um try and think of other stuff i can do i can do so much
i could do like And...
And then obviously there's the...
There's Dad.
Dad's above me here.
Ooh!
There's Dad right here.
You just want screenshots of Dad.
Here he is.
He's just chilling.
He's just having a good time.
Yeah, there he is.
Mm-hmm.
And then there he goes.
And then there's dragons.
Did you guys like the debut?
Do you guys like it?
And then there's the one with tears.
You guys liked it?
Really?
Really, guys?
I can't.
Oh, my God.
You guys liked it?
And also, oh, I can.
The red eye.
AIMBOT.
AIMBOT's on.
Legal AIMBOT.
Sorry.
Legal AIMBOT on.
So please don't report me because it's biologically on me.
There's no Clara shit here.
It's legal AIMBOT.
And...
Oh, wait.
Numbers?
Math?
Where am I?
Which left?
Where's north?
and then oh I like this face too
oh my god I hope you're taking all the screenshots we're
going so fast it's like modeling you know like modeling
you're supposed to make like like 10 poses per minute or
something because it's like I hope you guys are taking very
fast screenshots because I have so many expressions.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to having so many expressions that, like, I
have to go by so fast.
And then, um...
Oh, my God.
What's that?
Did you guys hear that?
Guys, I'm going to, like, never remember to use any of
these.
Oh, and, oh, yeah, my favorite one.
This is my favorite.
this is my favorite whoa you see the hair physics a lot
better too i can fight you with my neck oh it's like those
giraffe fights okay you know like giraffes that's how they
fight they swing their necks at each other and be like oh oh
that's how they fight that is how they fight and then normal
sparkle and be like
and then oh yeah jacket off the jacket comes off oh yeah and
then you see like you know my shirt is a little ripped there
and stuff the jacket comes on and aviators yeah i have my
aviators now on
i can make so many expressions i don't even need toggles
okay and then also gun that's really it that's all it does
gun you want to screenshot of just gun
just the gun the gun I'm gonna whip my gun out all right and
then the frowning one wait did I fuck it up
quick she can aim right now oh yeah finally uh dead inside
yes dead inside
wait no that's bad don't take don't take a screenshot that
wait no i i've i've seen those
all right and then uh it was like something else i think
that's is that everything is that all all right requests is
there any requests all right here's the full body too guys
any requests you guys want to do for your screenshots uh
don't use that as reference that's not done use don't use
that expression as reference uh upside no not upside death
but you can like flip it yourself uh aimbot eyes or glasses
okay glasses oh winking
okay it's better with the right eye
long neck with dad okay all right give me a sec i need to
like prep that oh all right all right i'll do three more
requests chat three more requests guys uh what else yeah
what are expressions you guys what dad's gonna throw up
no no no you're not getting that you're not i'm not doing
that for two dollars what the fuck
um uh no no no um oh sparkle wink without the jacket yeah we
can knew that with no jacket there you go um the price wink
uh will you do it for a hundred okay yeah i would actually
was it what was it what was it oh my god bed
That's okay.
That's all right.
No, that didn't happen, that didn't happen, guys.
That didn't happen, all right.
One more, one last one.
I'll do one more request.
I'll do one more request, guys.
Okay, bounty hunters gotta eat, okay?
It's not an easy job.
It's not, it's not, it's not an easy job, guys.
It did already got the screen.
Someone go delete FBI.
FBI, if you're watching me right now, FBI.
Get his agent to delete his screenshot right now.
Get the agent.
Get the FBI agent to delete his screenshot.
All right.
What do I do?
Red eye with left wing.
Okay.
That.
all right all right let's go back green screen purple screen
over purple screen has ended we go back now but yeah that
was great that was oh that was a lot i had honestly that was
a that's been oh my god my nerves i'm not as nervous and
anxious anymore i felt like I felt like, um, honestly felt
like I was, uh, re-debutting all, I mean, technically it is
re-debutting.
I felt like I was debuting all over again, too.
So, oh my gosh, I was so nervous.
Um, really a huge shout out to my project team for getting
all of that, for, like, getting my vision out there and, um,
being able to work on all of it.
And, um, even though we were a day late, um, the way it was
worth it um and it was uh it was had to definitely for them
and for me one of the most stressful projects we've ever
done because it was incredibly ambitious i've never been
able to do something this ambitious before when it comes to
like producing it and um like i said it's because of your
support guys um that was able to do something like this um
be able to plan something like this and afford to do
something like this so thank you dragoons for your support
and being able to help me fund um this passion project that
i did um and yeah but please check out my new merch uh from
uh um from my mama uh that they did my new acrylic stand um
that you can pre-order now um i love the visual art this is
going to be my new key visual now so i'm going to be using
this for like if i'm guessing at any places or something um
and they need a key visual i'll definitely be using this as
the main art uh for stuff like that um because i always
wanted a key visual art um and yes i couldn't have done it
without all of you guys i couldn't have been able to uh you
know be able to afford to do stuff like this and be able to
uh be able to do these passion projects and be able to
entertain you guys and have fun with all of you.
So thank you, dragons.
Thank you all.
Thank you all for the super chats.
Thank you all for the memberships.
Joining the tomato farm and supporting me.
I hope this new rebrand was worth it for you guys.
Because I know it's very different from retro dokey and i i
just really wanted to merge um past present together uh into
something that i felt was more like me and i'm so happy to
be able to work with my mama to do all of that and um and
yeah i was really surprised i remember sending that email
was like are you open to and you're like yes then i was so
happy and um we worked very hard together with clayia to and
cilia cilia actually gave input as well um uh gave input as
well when it came to this design and also my artist friends
like pokey and uh pokey and gg who helped me a lot my artist
friends um when i actually leaked the motto to them and
asked their advice as well um regarding like uh regarding
like what to do and stuff and uh and um yeah lots of work i
was so scared i was so nervous i was so anxious but it's
over it's over now we ripped the band-aid off and this is
what i look like now yay uh but yes anyway guys i think
that's really all i really want to say um i hope you guys
had a um great time today um great time watching and had a
lot of fun um i'll see you guys next time everybody as
always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it uh oh yes before i forget
um i will be a guest at Yusun's tour in Hong Kong.
Yes, I think I'm singing.
I think?
I should know by now.
It's in August.
I think I'm...
I am singing, yes.
It would be pretty awkward if I wasn't.
Yes, I'll be...
Next week, I'll also be at AVCon in Adelaide.
And I'll be as Bounty hunter dokey so i'll be bounty hunter
dokey at all my future conventions unless there's like you
know unless i want to i feel a little quirky and i swap
between between things but we'll see we'll see um avihal
will be the first time i'll be using bounty hunter dokey um
but yes i'll see you guys soon i'll see you guys tuesday for
behind the scenes hey guys bye everybody bye